y ahora
[Música]
buenas tardes y bienvenidos de nuevo
diversidad es el tema central de este
evento y es el tema central de mi mundo
de trabajo porque mi oficina es la selva
amazónica del departamento de madre de
dios
esta imagen solamente esta imagen puede
contener más de mil especies de árboles
este es diversidad
una cancha un área de una cancha de
fútbol puede tener más especies de todo
el continente de norte américa eso es
diversidad y dedicado los últimos 15
años en entender cómo funciona esta
diversidad cómo se mantiene la identidad
y la estabilidad de estos ecosistemas
hiper diversas
pero primero hablando de especies quería
aclarar que no soy una especie nativa
del perú
tengo origen exótico
en otras palabras soy como un mango
de origen hindú pero bastante cómodo y
aceptado en el perú o sea manguera
indica subespecie peruviana
mi viaje personal comenzó en la ciudad
de madrás ahora conocido como hn en el
sureste de la india donde nací y crecí y
como niño me encantaba leer
enciclopedias y artículos sobre biología
más que todo sobre la naturaleza y
quedaba impresionado de la selva
amazónica tenía este sueño de en alguna
manera experimentar la selva amazónica
personalmente y bueno luego decidí ir a
eeuu para estudiar y semi pregrado en
estudios medioambientales decidí empezar
un doctorado y fue en ese momento donde
tenía esta oportunidad increíble de
viajar por fin a la selva amazónica
gracias a mi asesor de doctorado que
había hecho mucho trabajo en madre de
dios
entonces llegué aquí en 2003 fue casi
directamente a la selva y ahí empecé mis
labores de los últimos 16 años
lo mejor que uno puede esperar
literalmente una alfombra verde sin fin
hasta el horizonte y estos bosques
contienen tanta diversidad de cualquier
grupo de vida pero el primero que me
impresionó me enamoré
con los árboles gigantes que tienen
siglos de vida que me parecen tan
elegantes e impresionantes que me gusta
referir a ellos como mega flora
carismática como esta luna que es el
árbol más alto de toda la amazonía oeste
que se llama a letón que un árbol que
puede tener aletas que miden hasta 20
metros siento muy humilde a la pgje de
estos árboles
la selva tiene varios animales especies
pequeños y grandes pero ciertas especies
tienen funciones muy muy importantes uno
de ellos es el mono araña conocido como
la máquina para en esas partes el otro
es la uane ghana es básicamente un
chancho nativo de la selva estos
animales se refieren a ingenieros de
ecosistemas aunque prefiero
considerarlos como artistas porque
literalmente diseñan estos ecosistemas
la existencia de tanta diversidad de
plantas con animales que dependen en las
plantas resulta en esto una co evolución
entre plantas que tienen que atraer a
los animales para estar transportados
por lo cual tienen frutos de diferentes
colores con pulpa muy nutritiva que
atrae el animal a tragar toda la fruta y
en el proceso transportar su semilla
pero existen varias especies también que
han decidido evolucionar sin la ayuda de
los animales para su dispersión tienen
varias formas de adaptación para volar
con el viento porque es necesario
alejarse del árbol madre de su madre
eso es básicamente lo fundamental de
estos bosques amazónicos que explica su
diversidad es la combinación de dos
procesos sencillas pero profundas
dispersión
y herbivoría dos maneras en cual los
animales interactúan con las plantas
ahora no soy el primero que ha sido
interesado en estudiarlo estoy ha sido
un tema que ha fascinado biólogos desde
el siglo 19 hace cincuenta años dos
biólogos famosos en el mundo de ecología
tropical juntaran toda la información
las observaciones y postularon una
hipótesis que está conocido como la
hipótesis de janssen y con él nombrado
por estos dos campos de la ecología y
les voy a dar la versión de dos minutos
que algo que consume casi cada día de
mis pensamientos que he pasado 15 años
en estudiar la hipótesis ofrece una
forma en que podemos mantener la
diversidad en bosques tropicales al
nivel del árbol individuo es la suma de
dos procesos que involucran animales uno
se refiere a la sombra de semillas
simplemente el hecho de que una pequeña
proporción de semillas no se cae
directamente debajo del árbol madre
están transportados
y el transporte por la mayor parte
facilitado las barrigas de animales
frívolos como la máquina para
porque es importante porque existe un
universo de lo que referimos a enemigos
naturales insectos adultos orugas hongos
u otros tipos de microbios que destruyen
todas las semillas no dispersadas según
la teoría con este resultado de que la
siguiente generación de cualquiera
especie no se encuentra debajo de la
copa o alrededor de la misma especie
sino a cierta distancia alejada
como se mantiene la diversidad este
mecanismo
bueno vamos a usar el alfabeto como un
ejemplo aquí tenemos 6 especies cada
representado por un alfabeto mayúsculo
los círculos se representan las áreas
donde cada especie no puede regenerarse
según la teoría eso abre espacio para
que cualquiera otra especie - esta
especie puede regenerarse y cómo se
llega como llega ahí por dispersión
facilitado mayormente por animales así
que este es un mecanismo para mantener
la alta diversidad de especies estamos
hablando de miles de especies de árboles
en madre de dios tenemos más de 2.000
especies de árboles
entonces la base de estos ecosistemas
son dos procesos fundamentales mediado
por animales dispersión y herbivoría
todo lo que les he presentado hasta
ahora es teórico pero en los últimos 15
años he dedicado esfuerzos para entender
para ver probar estas teorías y este es
un ejemplo una especie bastante común en
una área de 100 metros por 100 metros
una hectárea dos canchas de fútbol cada
símbolo verdadera presenta la ubicación
de un árbol de tamaño de ser adulto
reproductivo
en 10 años hemos podido confirmar donde
se caen las semillas las frutas y
semillas y se notan que están agrupados
alrededor de ciertos árboles y existen
áreas grandes en este área que parece
que no han recibido ni una semilla ahora
la pregunta para ustedes olvidando todo
de biología es donde pueden esperar
encontrar la siguiente generación de
esta especie
probablemente donde se encuentran la
mayoría de semillas a su edad
buena predicción
pero esta es la realidad cada triángulo
verde azul es un plantón un niño de esta
especie que llegada a un metro de altura
quiere presentar el fut la futura
generación
y se nota muy obviamente que cada
plantón
es el resultado de una semilla
dispersada alejado del agua madera esta
es la realidad
eso fue la gran parte de mi tesis de
doctorado basado en cual publicamos un
artículo preguntando si todas las
semillas son iguales o no y haciendo la
prueba el resultado es que
definitivamente no solamente las
semillas dispersadas contribuyen a la
siguiente generación por lo cual
contribuyen a la diversidad
entonces para resumir todo esto en
términos que todos pueden entender la
diversidad de bosques tropicales se
deben a dos procesos fundamentales en
todas nuestras vidas comer
y defecar
resulta en diversidad
un ecosistema tan complejo con tantas
especies basado en dos actividades
fundamentales mediados por animales
ahora en un mundo perfecto así será la
situación en toda la amazonía los
animales interactuando con las plantas
comiendo defecando haciendo girar el
mundo pero la realidad es un poco
diferente en los últimos 20 años en
varios lugares de amazonia e incluso en
madre de dios estos animales los
dispensadores han sido eliminados por
alta presión de cacería sin manejo
hasta que existe este término bosques
vacíos vacíos no de sus árboles pero de
esos animales sus dispensadores sus
artistas sus ingenieros y este es una
frase del primer artículo que que
formalizó es este fenómeno y me gusta
mucho porque nos dice que no es
suficiente tener árboles
necesitamos interacciones necesitamos
ecología en estos bosques
este es un ejemplo de lo que puede pasar
en la ausencia de dispersión
en un bosque con dispensadores esta
especie se nota que tiene mucha
dispersión y que la siguiente generación
está ubicado alejado de los árboles
madres qué pasa con la misma especie en
un bosque sin dispersión
básicamente
bastante de agregación
la siguiente generación está concentrado
está agregado en sí y cercano a los
árboles madres
este es el efecto de la ausencia de
dispersión bastante agregación
dominancia de pocas especies y con el
resultado de que al nivel de la
comunidad la diversidad se pierde esta
es la comparación entre un bosque con
dispensadores la línea azul y el bosque
sin dispensadores la línea roja y se
nota que
por cualquiera cantidad de individuos la
diversidad el número de especies está
bastante reducida
entonces el mensaje claro es que en
bosques amazónicos con reducir reducción
de dispersión menos diversidad más
agregación
y nos da cuenta que es muy importante
que los diseñadores los ingenieros están
conservados y protegidos porque sin
ellos encontramos un ecosistema bastante
reducido bastante simplificado
bueno espero que les pareció interesante
pero están probablemente pensando por
qué me importa fuera de la selva
amazónica y quería darles tres ejemplos
del pasado presente y futuro y por qué
les debe importar la primera alguien
sabía que el árbol en la bandera peruana
es la sección a la esquina no es la hoja
de coca por si acaso
este árbol es un héroe porque ha sido la
cura para el peor matador en la historia
de la humanidad la malaria
castaña es una especie emblemático de
madre de dios tiene una nuez bastante
delicioso con alta concentración de
grasa y antioxidantes hace unos años se
ha descubierto que el selenio natural
que tiene la castaña es muy efectivo
para retrasar el avance de alcemos
y al final mi ejemplo favorito
hace un mes estuve en un albergue en
madre de dios donde habían desarrollado
este cóctel exótico
casi 100% de ingredientes de la selva
menos la naranja
este es simplemente en la superficie de
las posibilidades con miles de especies
existe un mundo de sabores de
experiencia sensorial que nos falta
descubrir y les puedo confirmar que fue
una experiencia deliciosa
y nos esperan muchas más experiencias
deliciosas
entonces quería dejarles con algo para
pensar que como nos podemos inspirar los
bosques amazónicos en nuestras vidas
básicamente las semillas son ideas y los
mutualismo de entre los animales y las
plantas son colaboraciones debemos
colaborar debemos despertar nuestras
ideas porque es crítico para el
bienestar de la sociedad que tenemos una
diversidad de ideas
vivimos en un mundo con bastantes
problemas y necesitamos opciones
necesitamos diferentes formas y
soluciones
eso solo puede existir existir con una
diversidad de pensamientos
así que quería terminar dejándoles con
este mensaje por mi amigo el dispensador
disperse en sus ideas si saben algo que
les parece interesante comunican no los
dejan estancadas
y colaboren
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]